Hi, and welcome to CS215 Social Network Analysis.
My goal in this class is to give you an introduction
to the analysis and design of efficient algorithms.
We're going to focus on algorithms that will be useful to you
if you're trying to analyze large social networks.
I'm going to assume for this class that you have a familiarity with programming in Python
and that you're comfortable with mathematical notation
about at the level of high school Algebra 2.
Unit 1 is going to be a bit of a warmup.
I want you to think about how you design computer programs to solve particular problems.
What we're going to focus on is how we can take advantage of mathematical properties
of the problem that we're solving to speed things up.
I'm also going to introduce some social network terminology,
so that we'll be ready to dive into this topic a little bit more deeply in the later units.